[Musique]
quand on lit millions de spectateurs
français brouille 15 millions de
spectateurs français 6 millions de
spectateurs
d'accord près de 5 millions en 10
semaines 4e bras ou des films record du
tandem oury de funès jacques la neige
est rare depuis une pièce peu de jus
lyon nous avons joué neuf jours la fois
mon sort et on avait répété quatre mois
et demi je te signale un logement avec
l'on sait à peu près j'avais un tout
petit rôle lui faisait le rôle de talia
pendant la révolution et je faisais le
round 1 orion est il rentré il avait un
énorme chapeau avec des plus bleu blanc
rouge
il rentrait très sérieusement entrer
dans les normes saab à ce moment là la
salle éclaté de rire c'est à dire à peu
près 15 personnes à leurs côtés 30 sur
la simple c'était le masque de la prière
dans mon film le crime ne paie pas dans
lequel louis a joué pour la première
fois sous ma direction c'est à dire que
louis n'est même pas au générique du
film
il a fait un cachet à l'époque et ses
besoins louis louis jeune rôle d'un
barman et c'est au cours de ce 2e salon
sait jamais quand une journée importante
dans votre vie et sa 15 journées c'est
important pour moi cette journée là non
pas parce que nous tournions pour la
première fois ensemble sans s'en rendait
pas compte mais simplement parce que
c'était la seule scène comique du film
que j'avais écrit sur un coin du bar en
décor naturel dans lequel nous nous
trouvions et qu'à l'heure du déjeuner
déjeuner de production nous trouvions
tous ensemble louis m'a dit mais dis
donc toi pourquoi tu tournes dessine
normatif people toi tu es doué pour le
film comme et je veux te fout quoi
pourquoi librairie parce que tu ris
c'est la première fois que je voyais un
réalisateur rire vraiment à des choses
comique mais rire aux larmes se mettre
le mot gens dans la bouche un coin me
regarder de loin ils sont retournés pour
ne pas rater la prise j'ai vu louis dans
un café il est arrivé de sa femme et je
lui racontais l'histoire du corniaud est
tout de suite là sur le récit sans une
ligne creed il m'a dit tout à fait
d'accord je suis tout à fait d'accord
pour jouer ça alors j'avais fait aucun
film comique me parlait aussi de bourvil
voilà attendu et j'ai trouv
et instantanément que le nom à l'époque
beauville de funès faisait très insolite
s'était pas n'était pas de grosses
vedettes des gros mots qui font boum
c'était de nous qui piquait alors j'ai
été trouvé bourvil et je lui ai parlé je
vais également raconté l'histoire et
sans qui rien d'écrit à la fois louis et
andres était révulsée bourvil ont
accepté de tourner le corniaud et j'ai
commencé à écrire le film tourné en un
an plus tard et qui est en somme le
commencement c'était en a vendu car nous
avons eu ensuite le recevra trompés ils
ont eu cornillon les ont eu la grande
vadrouille où nous avions beau ville et
nous avons eu ensuite nous ont tourné
ensemble la folie des grandeurs avec
yves montand et plus récemment
évidemment les aventures de rabbi jacob
le débat je suis intraitable et
d'eiffage et orange je voulais pas sûre
de la scène
une scène avec les motards n'ont jamais
vu la scène un peu pas trivial harper
peu vulgaire je sais pas et pas du tout
je me trompais je me suis mis dans la
tête
[Musique]